lo psicopatico un manipolatore scusa
perché ti stai giocando non casta non ho
capito che stanno lì da katie trucchi
cioè non l'ha mai fatto voglio dire a
chi tv far vedere venitevi far vedere
che esci fuori trucchi o e poi avevo
detto di cambiare i capelli di farti la
francia quella di che parliamo al mento
per non farti vedere fino a qua no no tu
sempre di rispetto che tranquilla è
certi di una colazione perché ti amo
grazie ma rimanendo a cena la mangiata
manigrasso se non funziona scusa il
burbero tenere un incoerente ma che
nessuno non ho detto spesso mi viene
famiglia quella dove no no no no no
aiuto bsn mio sfondo che sono
utilizzabili e molto legato
la scusa ai capelli lunghi assoli e il
fisico 26 piccoli fiumi and bass e tette
sioux tobias a questo sia tobias ma
perché non ho bisogno ma non voglio i
vincoli o lo sai che non me ne frega
niente di queste cose l'amore che cagate
a capitanare non ho bisogno di nessuno
bisogna dire no no no ti prego rimane
quindi il pannolino
il senza personalità alcuna no ridevo
per un pensiero è più di un'idea
ma il frutto per marito per una cosa che
che battuta c'è un cosa personaggio che
è molto di questo ragazzino
bravis quello quello che interpreta l'ex
no no no ovvio moro infatti però che può
sembrare un po biondo un monologo si si
si si si appassiona beh cambia qualche
perché il cantante preferito
nonostante preferito a parte unica
ascolti tu che secondo me sono demandate
ne avremmo preferito sulla si justin
timberlake è il mio preferito
nel senso che al mano se l'abbiamo già
20 justin timberlake è secondo solo ad
albano l'insicuro frignone tu ci tieni a
me
certo che ci tengo mi ami
certo amore ma se tu dovessi scegliere
di chi buttare nella lava tra trame la
tua migliore amica l'infanzia chi
sceglieresti ma che domanda è capito
mattino scegli rucci di meucci di
massimo queste cose che vuol dire che
non sei scene ma non c'è non ma come
faccio a scegliere una pace uccidila di
brega la vinci di là l'egocentrico di
merda amore sa perché ti amo perchè non
certo senso mi ricordi mento e sai
perché mi ricordi mento
perché negli occhi meravigliosi e a
volte mi sembra mi sembra tipo di
guardarmi allo specchio quando sto
vicino al tempo e un carattere a tua
simpatia cavolo dici le stesse battute
si è troppo forte perché sia una donna
forte come me del resto sono una persona
in gamba starebbe con una in gamba come
me se solo potessi autori produrmi
paradiso il pignolo palo in culo tutto
sbagliato ma come amore no a te lo dico
io ha messo in canna hai messo i bianchi
tutti separati cioè sostendendo di nuovo
così si stropiccia dio santo ti prego
scusami il secondo dai per favore ma che
lo stupido ma non lo fa ma io lo devo di
lavare adesso dai non abbiamo spirare
tutto mi stai suolo scassa capsico
tentato marine facendo a controllo della
distanza tra questo buffone e lara croft
è arrivata non cambia disti capelli dai
è ridicolo non mi ricordino mia ex ti
prego cioè con claudia finita malissimo
ti prego no
ok è accusato è arrivato il capezzolo
siccome faccio la chiamo amore lo
psicopatico arrapato ma c'è un altro
modo per dirmi che mi sta lasciando un
modo per dirmi che non te ne fregato
niente che cos'era l'ultima botta e via
sa che facciamo li lascino ti lascio
prima io presente dove abiti io lo so è
presente tu madre occhio puffi yo soy
abile scorta la tentate rigo che faccio
fuffi la lapide il rincoglionito cronico
no grazie ma non prende tra due mesi è
infatti non è il mio compleanno oggi è
oggi è vediamo se lo sai
allora diciamo insieme veloce lo sai che
non mi fido 3 2 1 con imera dario
anniversario bravissima che belli
bellissimi come mary mary mary mary da
matteoli non mi ricordo l'avversario
certo ciò regalo per te è che così può
il potere stili reti in testa come mi
chiamo magari merita ti prego non fare
così mettiamo il calore
spontaneo amore ok go
dimmi qualcosa di carino se molto bella
me gusta arriva arriva
ma ok ma ci sposeremo noi due non ho
capito bene ok go
quando ci sposiamo impossibile
connettersi alla rete wifi
ok go dove andiamo a mangiare stasera ci
sono cinque ristoranti qui vicino
altrimenti dell'ottima carta in casa il
silenzioso succube amore ma va beh ti
devo raccontare allora è presente giulia
è praticamente mi ha appena detto al
telefono che ha fatto uno di quegli
incidenti commercio che è stato minimo 5
taglie ci sono tremila primi infatti non
so mai quale scegliere to quelle
vedresti sia 13 modelli guarda non lo so
a vestirmi le scelte da fare non so mi
piacerebbe tanto stare nella sabbia
quando là fuori c'è la neve non fare la
cacca la fanno spruzzo ma proprio
potente perché così non sporcano il lido
fa sempre cose troppo troppo grassi da
mangiare potrebbero creare minimo una
moneta da 0,90 centesimi perché come al
solito ogni volta che si danno un resto
sempre di una minima
nella vita mi sembra anche affida il
povero singolo è pazzo nostra lasciato
un'altra volta
ne sta sempre con me e sapete cosa ho
deciso che dopo dio non riuscite
lestamente scala mi innamorerò una
persona che sceglie le scale provocando
il pannolino performer
ci risiamo ragazzi non piacciono
verticali quando ti potrai orizzontale e
ti metti così capitoli il corpo sono
verticali di
[Musica]
[Risate]
casa dai enrico ma che per caso si
aspettano che la donna di mettere non
sopra l'altra doga negli spazi invece
tutine che sopra l'altra è una persona
intelligente come tester è bene con lo
può vedere come make up
ok è arrivato un capezzolo
perché se la persona più immaginifica
del mondo perché così così puoi
iscriverti il tuo nome in faccia
qualcosa di carino per favore sei molto
bella e giusta cioè dell'ottima carta
[Applauso]
quando non farei a cambio la fanno
spruzzo ma proprio potente perché così
non sporcano il lido e neanche se stessa
immagine perché sai bianco davanti
potrebbe macchiarsi poi come lo sono